BLAIR: Well, I think was well worth
the rest of it, Nick.
Listen, when you talk about a
demeaning political
discourse, try the British House of Commons:
the Prime Minister's question time.
It kind of defines a demeaning political discourse, I would say.
WOLTERSTORFF: I take it you sometimes felt yourself demeaned there?
BLAIR: I very seldom felt myself anything else.
Listen, here's some good news-- because we've
we've had with us some of
the people from the other universities
who are now taking this course
from-- from around the world, and actually
the things that we're debating here are
things that they are debating too,
in a very lively and interesting way,
and so I think what--
it's-- it's
kind of good to think that we're a part of a broader movement.
And actually what I want to do is to build
very much on what
Nick has just said, because I'd just like to
say I agree with it.
I just agree with it.
And I want to try to take this debate
to the next stage because I think that
the classic divide--
and I found this reading the literature
for--
for what we're going to do today--
the classic
divide
in this debate is
on the one side, religious people saying, "We've
got the right to enforce our views against--
against you,"
and then the secular liberals
come back and say, "Keep your religion
out of the public realm." And
it's then-- when we,
we analyze these things, it's not just about
the constitution, because
there can be all sorts of
things that are outside the
constitution that can still make a difference
to how
religion is viewed. I mean, for example--
I don't know, and you tell me, but--
I think if you're an American presidential
candidate and stood up and said, "I don't
believe in God,"
you'd probably find it--
I mean your campaign manager would say,
"I don't think you should say that-- not--"
Your strategist and your pollster would be leaping
out of their seats.
So, you know,
even if it's not-- you know,
sometimes religion can have an influence
outside of the formal nature
of-- of
the debate
in terms of the constitution. But the classic
divide--
the religious people saying, "We decide," and the secular
liberals saying, "Get out of the public realm,"
I personally think you can move on from
that, really.
And--
because what is clear that--
as Nick has just said--
the democracy, pluralist democracy--
or, let me say this-- actually a pluralist
society,
because I think some of these things apply
even to non-democratic societies
that are pluralist--
they require a common space
where difference can be accommodated,
but where certain values or norms are shared.
Right, so that people are respected
irrespective
of their
religious commitment--
whatever their own religion says about certain
issues,
nonetheless they accept, they come on a common
space at a certain point,
and have to expect that public face in
the valleys and norms of-- within it.
So, I think most people understand that, even if they're
strongly religious, actually.
Most people.
Not everyone, but I think most do.
And also-- and I think this is where the
thing has moved on from
Rawls's time--
although there are people who still
come up with some quite intemperate stuff on
this-- but
I think most people
believe also that religion can't be excluded
from the public realm.
In other words, it's one thing to say,
"I, as a religious thinker--
I'm going to determine
the public realm." It's quite another thing to
say, "I simply want to be--
my voice to be heard."
Now that, at its minimal, I think most people would
say nowadays, "Well, yeah, of course that's true."
And incidentally,
the fact is-- which I would
make for a practical point of view--
if you are of religious belief,
in a sense you can't
exclude it; it defines you. So
there is no way that you could have a
public debate in which your religious
is not somehow
relevant to you, and therefore relevant
to the debate that is occurring within
the public realm. So
my view is that
this debate is not
really about
liberal versus religious,
in the sense of
the way that, say, O'Donovan uses it, whereas
the liberal is really a sort ofa
contractarian-- I think he said that, is that the right--
the expression is that it's to do simply
with the contract--
whereas the religious people are the people
with the values.
That is almost the suggestion I found
in that writing.
It seems to me that
even if you are--
if you take
a non-religious view,
of
human rights,
nonetheless--
as, indeed,
Rawls was pointing out--
behind any constitution of rights,
there will lie
certain ideals, and those ideals are inspired by
certain
values.
So, it isn't really true to say that the
person who's
a secular liberal,
and says, "Look, religion shouldn't come into
this debate," is really arguing from the point
of view of saying,
"I think this is just a personal contractual
issue;
it's got nothing to do with larger society."
In the same way,
as I say, that in my view most
people who are religious
do in fact accept
that there is a common space and a common
constitution written or unwritten
to which they must conform.
In addition to that,
I think that no one seriously
thinks nowadays that society doesn't require
certain values to underpin it.
Whether you're religious or you're secular.
Most people talk about certain values
that lie behind
whatever is the constitutional, the legal laws
to which people are expected to--
to conform.
And even the most non-religious
politicians, certainly, in societies like ours--
you know, I think
they-- they're not merely motivated by certain values,
but they see them--
see themselves as representing certain values.
And
I think the people
are perfectly prepared,
mostly
to see
those who are of religious belief
at least having the right to participate
in the debate
and the right to say-- because how can they
say otherwise--
that their view of a particular debate
is motivated by their religious belief.
So I think it's really--
when we come to this
supposedly very strong divide
between
the secular and the religious,
I think most people have resolved
that debate in their own mind. I'm not saying that
there aren't still people at the extremes on either side
who will say
on the religious side, "I want to determine
the way that society works;
I'm not prepared to accept,
my religion impels me
to act in a way inconsistent with the constitution"--
as Nick was explaining-- I'm sure there are people like that,
there are people like that--
there are people on the other side
as you saw with the
statement from Jacoby, which is very much, you
know, just--
"Get out of there, you shouldn't be anywhere
near this debate"-- but I don't--
I think most people
accept
that society's based on certain values, and
some of those values will derive from religion and
some of those values won't, but there's a place,
often, that is common and overlapping.
I think the more
interesting questions now
are really
these, however:
in order to make
a society
work effectively,
what is it
that is necessary
for
religious and non-religious people to agree
upon
in order for that society to function well?
Now I agree with the two principles that
Nick has just outlined, and let me try and
put this in my own way
and develop it somewhat.
I think,
first of all, that
people who are secular
need to understand also
that the religious dimension
can give a
quality
of a moral nature
to the debate within society
that can be
helpful and constructive and progressive.
So, for example, I would say that of
the debates about
Western policy in relation, let's say, to
Africa and the third world debt--
the impact of those inspired by religion had
a significant impact
on the political decisions that were then
taken by leaders. I would say that the G8, which I
presided over in 2005, would never have
come to its conclusions
without a very strong
religious movement
here, back in Europe, and
elsewhere in support of
that.
And actually one of the big changes in the
whole issue to do with HIV/AIDS and how it
was
treated in Africa
was when
many of the Christian movements here
decided to get over
various of the
sexual issues in relation to HIV/AIDS and actually
embrace the notion that it was an important
part of their
religious
duty in order to deal with this--
this issue, and
in fact,
much of the health care that is delivered
in Africa today is delivered by religious organizations.
So I think--
and I would--
it is a
very controversial idea to raise
this in--
if you take an issue like abortion, which is
very very controversial
in my society, and even more so in your society,
leave aside whether you agree or disagree
with the positions of religious people on it--
but I think that
it's not unhelpful
to actually have issues that are difficult
like that raise,
in a context that is spiritually or religiously
defined-- now that doesn't mean to say that
you end up with the same position of--
of, let's say, the Catholic church on that
issue or not.
But I think
even secular people should recognize
that it's a debate that's still important to have,
and it's a debate that might not have taken
place in the same way unless
religious people had been prepared to put it on
the agenda.
Now, likewise, I think that once
society comes to a view,
that view has to be accepted--
by the religious people also--
but all I'm saying is there are--
what I think the second people need to understand
is
that there can be
a way of raising questions-- that's why I do agree
with O'Donovan-- a way of raising
questions
and actually the establishment of an agenda
in which religious and spiritual thought
can play part, and play a positive part--
because otherwise some issues would not
get raised at all.
And--
you know, I think, for example,
of the work done by many
church organizations in relation
to the disabled. Now it's true there are many people
who are not religious at all who raise these
issues, but I would have to say,
certainly in my society, the most extraordinary
and selfless work is done by religious organizations
in this sphere. So.
That's the first thing.
The second thing, however--
and I think the concomitant
obligation
is the people who
are religious
also
need to understand
that those who do not
conform to a view derived from religious
belief
nonetheless have equal validity to state that
belief,
adhere to it, and advocate it.
And
this is where,
if you like the concept of faith-friendly
democracy, or
democracy-friendly faith,
it's so important-- you need that balance
if you're going to achieve
a proper settlement of the place of religion
within society.
But I think this is not just about democracy
and that's-- I just want to make this amendment,
in a sense, to our--
our discussion.
I think it is
possible
to have a non-democratic-- certainly in the sense of
non-democratic in a Western sense--
political system
that nonetheless is pluralist and nonetheless
has a--
the same
relationship that I'm describing
between religious faith
and politics.
What is essential
is the notion of pluralism.
If you don't have the exact--
the question of pluralism,
the issue of pluralism there,
that concept rooted in the society--
then I think it's very difficult.
And so my view is that
this very--
what I would call quite extreme, almost a slightly
old-fashioned sense
of a divide between
those people who say,
"My religion entitles me to enforce my
view against you,"
and those people who say, "Actually, you
take your religious views out of here; we don't
want anything to do with that,
and it's not a legitimate basis upon which you
can put your case,"--
I think that is largely--
people-- as I say, I'm not saying that it doesn't
exist, but I don't think that's what most people
find difficult today.
Most people can accept
that religious people have a right to
express their view, most religious people
can accept that they don't have the
right to enforce it.
I think the question is, though, what are the conditions
that--
that give rise
to
that
faith-friendly
society and a society-friendly faith.
And those-- in my view-- are,
as I say, that the secular needs to understand
the religious connections
enrich
the social and moral dialogue of a nation,
and the religious need to understand that
those who aren't religious have equal validity
in their views.
The question, to my mind, then becomes the practical
question
of how you best create such societies.
And here's
where I think
the political and the social and the faith
conditions
for such societies are
an interesting subject of analysis and
discussion, because--
and it may be it's just because of
my background-- I kind of
think it's interesting to analyze the question
and
even more interesting to
find an answer to the question--
and so,
what is it
that-- that gives rise to this?
Because I can describe and just have what are
the attitudes, but how do you encourage
those attitudes?
How do you abet those attitudes?
And here's where I think that the--
the policy,
in a sense, that flows from this,
is as follows: I think,
to begin with,
there does need to be
some clear
constitutional
or legal framework within which this is set,
and the full principles that Nick outlined,
they're behind the US Constitution.
Those
undoubtedly helped create
the sense in the US today that there
is a legitimate and an illegitimate way of having
the debate between
religion and politics.
So I think that is important.
I think secondly,
none of this
would work without
action to support it. I think this-- what we're
talking about is radical implications, for
example, for our education system,
and I think in particular the way that religion is taught
within our education system
within civic society.
Within international engagement-- for example,
the alliance of civilizations concept put
forward by Turkey
and Spain--
in some process of development now-- is
actually important
in this regard.
And so if we want to create that society
in which there is the balance
of the proper space for religion,
to make its view clear,
but also the--
the broader polity that must encompass more
than the religious--
I think it requires
that constitutional framework,
it requires policy
on behalf of government that supports
such attitudes,
and the third thing that it needs, and this is--
which touches directly on our
faith and globalization course--
is it does require a certain attitude of mind.
And this is where I find it--
it's quite interesting just listening to
Nick's analysis of the
way that
the intellectual debate has
gone.
In the end, what this requires is
what I would call an open rather than a closed
attitude
to both the process of globalization in the society
in which we live,
and how you inculcate that attitude
has also got to be part
of the
the discourse in and around this subject.
Because, you see, ultimately,
in order for this balance to work,
in order for us to be able to say, as Nick has
really
outlined for you, that
you should not exclude
the religious, the religious has a place and
a voice, but nonetheless that is within certain
rules and with certain
qualifications
to how that voice should be spoken--
in order to do that
and in order to have a society work like that,
there needs to be within the people in that
society
a certain openness to the other.
So that, for example,
someone who is religious
is not merely
not exclusivist toward with those of other religions,
but is actually prepared to acknowledge that
the secular can sometimes have
something to say to the religious world.
But it also requires-- and actually
this is--
has often, I think,
far more resisted-- that those that are secular
should also realize that those who are religiously
inspired
have something
to offer and to add to
the forum within which political debate
is conducted.
So, to summarize,
my view is this:
that
this is--
I think there is a developing consensus
that you do require
faith-friendly
democracy, democracy-friendly faith, or
faith-friendly society,
society-friendly faith--
the question is how you
achieve such a
thing, and in order to achieve it,
you need a combination of
the right constitutional framework
the right policy
and the right attitude.